g
ouais
bonjour monsieur
le metteur en scène monsieur je m'excuse
de 2,2 m'excuser enfin e et de vous
demander par enfin non je vous demande
rien je voulais juste vous dire que je
suis venu pour la l'audition que vous
m'avez demandé
et comme je suis venu et pas je suis là
je suis là parce que je suis venu enfin
bon j'ai donc appris le texte que j'ai
choisi enfin j'ai pas choisi parce que
s'est imposée et c'est un texte de
commencer de de racine
voilà c'est le racing le texte de racine
le texte
non non non c'est pas racine 1 ça y est
c'est l'eau au delà il ya ils sont deux
on dit toujours si c'est pas racine
c'est donc commencer un corner voilà où
un ton en dessous aupa bo me je m'excuse
je me calme du givet est tout de suite
alors j'y vais alors là rôle non ah ça y
est ça commence
le pièce non
non alors rolls et corneille dans emilie
de sinon pièce c'est ml dans corneille
de sinon ya tout un mais j'arrive pas de
bon écoute et alors moi ce qu'on va
faire c'est comme j'arrive pas à le dire
et pas je vais le dire
enfin me dire comme je n'arrive pas à
dire le trip le titre je vais dire le
l'oeuvre le le volta c'est de tous les
côtés un y à rien
bon j'y vais parce que ça tout de suite
oui alors quand je regarde auguste bon
y'a surement pas bon bah oui aubin
bon ben moi j'arrête au badge aucune
chance quand même franchement si moi je
veux bien mais ça va recommencer comme
l'année dernière à chaque fois c'est bon
je le dis parce que tout de suite mais
quand je regarde augus et que vous
présentez à ma triste mémoire
mon père massacrer du trône où je le
vois fait le premier degré bon alors moi
qu'est ce que je fais dans ce top là ça
y est en bas nous allons alors là
j'arrête à celui qui fait que ça c'est
valable un mois je bon je le dis oui
pour finir le oui pour en finir ambarès
je crois plus du tout du tout du tout
malheur encore moins de tout à l'heure
j'ai brassé pour une mort lui de voir
mille morts au moins
y a pas au moins oui on parle
vilas et là c'est la fin du s'est finie
ça manque de travail à oui pour moi
c'est ce que je dis toujours le travail
le travail seulement on était parti avec
des copains et puis on part donc non
pour écouter alors non ce qu'on va faire
assez vous allait m'envoyer votre photo
repas dont non non non je m'excuse
monsieur le commissaire monsieur le
monsieur lemay torrance on va prendre
des photos et puis on va se les envoyer
non écoutez moi je vous dis à bientôt
non bon ou si on se croisait dans un
couloir non plus n'ont alors je vous
devine une autre fois petit fils ou